there really haven't been that many
things I would describe as unique you
know there's no gay way to change a
diaper except in certain sex clubs I
would expect and you know I didn't grow
up obsessing about my parents genitalia
you know I knew my mom was a woman and
my dad was a man but I didn't think
about their genitalia all the time there
were people there were my parents and he
seems to regard us in that same way
there have been some moments that were
pretty hilarious where he insisted he
was going to be gay when he grows up
like us because you know he didn't like
girls at 9:00 and we had to let him know
that at 9:00 we only liked girls and
that was a pretty good sign that he was
actually going to be straight when he
grew up but he didn't like girls at 9:00
so the certain things you know errors of
you know certain assumptions he's made
based on what he's observed that her
down on to be truly to disabuse him up
and was heartbreaking thing kind of
happened recently where he didn't want
to tell us about something that was
going on so he didn't think we would
understand because we were gay and he
was straight and so he wanted to you
know he felt he couldn't talk to us
about straight stuff and that's kind of
heartbreaking because you know when we
were kids we felt we couldn't talk to
our parents about gay stuff when we were
12 because we were hiding from our
parents we didn't want them to know we
were gay because we were afraid of what
they might do and it was sort of
heartbreaking to realize that he had
sort of landed in the same place and was
afraid to talk to us about things about
his you know private life even at 12
because he didn't think we'd understand
because we were gay and he was straight
and we you know had we talked about that
and now he tells his stuff no he talks
to us about it but at first he felt like
we wouldn't you know we wouldn't be able
to help them and that was kind of sad I
kind of broke both our hearts but we got
through it